good morning to you whatever time it is
where you are I'm Dave Ruben this is the
Ruben report it's September 19th 2023
we're live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and locals tap that notification Bell
subscribe if you have not for God's
sakes don't make me beg you and if you'd
like to join us for a postgame show oh
wait a minute do we have a postgame show
today or there yes we do have a postgame
show today they were doing a little
backend work over at locals we do have a
postgame show Ruben report. locals.com
all right I have to address three
important things that happened on
yesterday's show before we even get into
it today three major things that
happened first off at the end of
yesterday's show I was talking about
cancel culture and how one day they're
going to come for all of us all of us
have done things we're not proud up we
had sex with someone we did drugs this
or that we hung out with some unruly
people whatever it might be and what I
addressed was that when I was in about
third grade growing up uh my friend Chad
had Skeletor the He-Man character
Skeletor and I had Skeletor too and you
guys know Skeletor was the main guy
going against He-Man Skeletor had a
staff it was known as the Havoc staff it
was a little purple plastic staff I lost
mine and I stole Chad's I have been
living with this for almost 40 years
okay I have never said anything about it
but I know they were going to come get
me one day so I addressed it on the show
I have not seen Chad or talked to Chad
heard from Chad anything in about 15
years I mention it on the show yesterday
I was then looped in on a text via
another childhood friend with Chad and
Chad has accepted my apology so Chad I
thank you for that and the point of all
of this guys is if you if you have a
Maya kulpa if you say I've done
something bad the world will forgive you
that's one thing I have to address the
next thing I have to address uh slightly
more serious is that during the show
yesterday at the end I was giving Bill
Mah credit because Bill Mah had decided
to go against the writers Union and
bring his show back he was going to do
it without a monologue he was going to
do it without uh you know new rules and
some of the stuff that the writers do
but he was going to bring it back mostly
as a panel in an interview show
realizing that although the writers may
have some just points and he's one of
the writers himself uh that that there
are plenty of other people the sound
guys the lighting guys the makeup people
that nobody's working nobody's making
money and he decided to bring the show
back because he didn't want to harm
everybody so I was giving him credit for
it during the show and I think about two
minutes after we ended the show Bill Mah
retracted that statement and put out a
new one uh my decision to return to work
was made when it seemed nothing was
happening and there was no end in sight
to this strike now that both sides have
agreed to go back to the negotiating
table I'm going to delay the return of
of real time for now and hope that they
can finally get it done anyway we'll see
maybe he knows something that it really
is about the pieces are about to be put
together and they'll all come back as I
said yesterday I don't think anyone's
really siding with the writers I don't
think anyone misses The Tonight Show or
the late show or the late tonight show
or the tonight late show or any of the
daytime shows or any of the nonsense and
once you remove the writers you kind of
see how talentless you know guys like
Kimmel and Co bear and the rest of these
characters are okay so those are two
things and now this one actually is
seriously serious you know I mentioned
that yesterday on the show that this
Russell Brand nonsense and that I was
not going to address it again so I am
not going to address the the accusations
against him again because my gut feeling
is that they're completely baseless and
and even if they're not this is just the
machine doing what it always does when
someone steps out of bounds but
something else very interesting happened
this morning uh I saw this tweet by Viva
fry viva's been on the show many times
he wrote Russell Brand demonetized on
YouTube and the new rule has been
implanted you will now get demonetized
on YouTube YouTube if your off-platform
behavior quote harms its ecosystem I'm
sure this economic censorship is going
to only be used with extreme parsimony
and will never be politically weaponized
and then he quotes this is the exact
quote in their TOS their terms of
service if a Creator's off platform
Behavior harms our users employees or
ecosystem we take action to protect our
community so you must understand this
Russell Brand has a huge amount of
followers viewers Etc on YouTube now
he's he's a rumble guy like I'm a rumble
guy that might have more to do with what
this is really about just taking out the
competition but the idea that they would
demonetize you or potentially delete
your Channel or whatever other tricks
they have because of something you did
off platform think about that you
watching this right now you have a
YouTube account you might have an
Instagram account a Twitter account
whatever it might be if they don't like
what your behavior might be you went to
that bar with that person you did that
thing 25 years ago they can either
deplatform you or demonetize you etc etc
this is deeply dangerous and I want to
mention one other thing about it this
idea of off platform when I saw that
phrase it clicked something for me you
may remember for those of you that have
been with me for for years now about six
seven years ago when I was crowdfunding
on patreon that's how we funded the show
when I first went
independent a guy by the name of Carl
Benjamin better known as Sargon of aad
uh was he was a big YouTuber he was sort
of in the classical liberal space when I
was kind of waking up about what the
modern left was doing anyway he was on
patreon as well and patreon booted him
for something that he did not do on
patreon and as many of you may remember
Jordan Peterson and I we were on tour at
that time we both decided to leave
patreon because of that the idea that
you could just be booted from an online
service for something that had nothing
to do with what you were doing on that
online service I then created locals
because of that and we ultimately merged
with Rumble the point of all of that is
it's happening again right now but
fortunately there are alternatives like
Rumble and locals but off platform once
they're saying that to the creators
they're saying it to you too behave or
we're going to take away your Facebook
but speaking of Behaving uh let's talk
about the Senate today because this is
where we're going to kick off the show
uh the Senate I mentioned to you
yesterday Chuck Schumer announced that
the Senate is changing their rules
related to the dress code where men
basically have to be in a suit you know
a jacket and tie and women have to kind
of be in business attire it's been this
way for decades it leads to a certain
amount of decorum you might say it's too
stuffy it's theater blah blah blah but
they are changing it and basically
allowing anyone to wear whatever they
want because of John fedman up in
Pennsylvania who wants to basically
dress like a Philadelphia and crack atct
and I think this is a really bad move
it's not necessarily about that you have
to dress exactly with the suit and the
shirt and everything else but we are
removing all of our norms and standards
from society we're removing all of the
things like be a little bit better get a
haircut that kind of works make sure
that you brush your teeth and everything
else and I think we can link this really
to the to the uh complete collapse of
sort of all of our Norms in society are
boys girls anymore is America
fundamentally
racist and I will link all of that to
how even our pundit class which includes
colleagues of mine have been now
captured by just whatever the thing of
the day is if there is something
happening on the day and it's shiny and
it's got a lot of energy and it's going
to get you clicks a whole bunch of
people are going to go in that direction
and usually that direction has nothing
to do uh with what is true which perhaps
is what brings you to this show so we
will talk about all of that but first
let me tell you guys about gravity to
fire you know how much is it worth to
not feel pain with every step you take
from walking the dog to running the kids
from school to practice it takes a toll
well you need to check out gravity to
Fire Shoes whether you're wearing them
on the job or to get your daily step
count up these gravity def fire shoes
are revolutionary walking and running in
normal shoes creates shock waves that
course through your feet knees and hips
forcing the body to absorb as much as
1,000 lbs of harmful impact with every
step gravity to fire shoes are
clinically shown to relieve knee pain in
a double blind study by Olive View UCLA
Medical Center published in the Journal
of American podiatric Medical
Association participants experiened 85%
less knee pain it's the most powerful
shock absorption system put into a shoe
so here's the deal try a pay try a pair
for 60 days and experience the
difference they can make in your life
buy a pair today and save 15% with free
returns and easy exchanges you've got
nothing to lose visit gravity.com use
code Ruben for a 15% discount on your
first order test a pair risk-free and
experience the difference in your life
gravity def fire.com use code ruin for
15% discount on your first order gravity
to fire.com order today and now back to
me all right so John fedman the fact
that this man is in the Senate is an
embarrassment to all of us no one in
their right mind and he's not in his
right mind but no one in their right
mind thinks he's qualified no one thinks
he has the mental Acumen there's a lot
going on there we all know it poor Dr Oz
whatever you thought the limitations of
Dr Oz was whether you thought he was a
native Pennsylvanian or not or you
thought he was just too much of a slick
TV salesman or whatever the poor guy
lost to John freaking fedman and now
thanks to Hoodie wearing John fedman the
standards that the Senate have been
thrown out here's a tweet from Chad
pergam about what the Senate is doing
Fox confirms that the Senate will no
longer enforce a dress codee for
senators Senators can wear now whatever
they want however others entering the
chamber must comply with the dress code
coats and ties for men business attire
for women let's do the second part of
that first I mean how insane is that so
the Senators can wear whatever they want
a guy can wear a dress a girl could wear
a a leather Catwoman costume from Batman
2 what's her name Michelle fight for
everybody like that thing that's just
fine but if you as a citizen of the
United States show up to the senate for
a meeting or to see what's going on
you'd like to wander in and you know
just say hi to people you have to dress
up
appropriately that in and of itself
putting aside whether these people
should be dressed a certain way or not
like we are held we the people will be
held to a higher standard than the
people who are supposed to be
representing Us in Washington DC that's
completely bananas but again this idea
that we're just going to sort of break
down all of the normaly in society look
I'm not like an uppity
uh like you you have to dress a certain
way I have one rule what's my one rule
in this studio Connor say it out loud my
one rule no shorts that's the Dave ruin
Ruben report Studio rule it do I get it
we're in Florida it's hot sometimes it's
110 and it's humid as hell I don't want
to see anyone's white legs that's the
policy around here but beyond that I say
guys you dress how you want here and
everyone does relatively dress in a work
manner I I'm wearing pants you know what
though I will show you guys I'll admit
can I move around a little bit here I'm
not wearing shoes I'm wearing sliders
I'm going to get some real crap for that
I'm wearing socks with sliders today but
I am not a senator okay and I do think I
clean up okay with this kind of
thing the idea that we will break down
all of the Norms is just another piece
in breaking down everything that seems
to be breaking down like you everyone
knows this when when you take a shower
you clean up you shave tight you do your
hair right you put on a jacket a shirt
you put on a gown a nice dress whatever
it is you feel better right you feel
better Jordan Peterson has talked a lot
about this right you you will actually
like you're presenting something to the
world one of the things that I see all
the time now when I'm on planes is
people dress dirty sweatshirts and and
flipflops and and all this stuff and
it's like man if you look at what people
used to wear when they got on a plane or
when they went to the theater 30 40
years ago versus now it's like do you
think we're going in the right Direction
Carol Roth who I've had on the show
she's a she's a fantastic author she put
this tweet up and I thought this was a
really nice example of it of what's
going on here this is fans dressed for a
baseball game in the 1950s and a senator
dressed for work in 2023 I mean look at
those people in the stadium now I'm not
saying everybody has to wear a suit and
a tie and all of that to go to a
baseball game of course not I have never
worn a suit and a tie to go to a
baseball game Connor you went to a
Marlins game last week did you you wear
a suit and a tie he did not okay maybe a
baseball cap and a t-shirt that's okay
but you guys see the Meltdown of
everything no no one nothing will ever
be something to strive for it will just
be a constant depression of all of the
Norms that we have Marjorie Taylor green
you might think this about her you might
think that about her I thought she made
a good point on this one she said the
Senate no longer enforcing a dress code
for senators to appease Federman is
disgraceful dress code is one of
society's standards that set etiquette
and respect for our institutions stop
lowering the bar and it's it's that it's
the stop lowering the bar can we aspire
to be a little bit better than we are
you know when I do this show every day
and we talk about politics and
politicians and lying we ever aspire to
be a little bit better where we'll elect
people who will dress properly who won't
lie who will know basic math who will
know basic biology maybe we can't do
that right and so we are we will we
either are there already or we will
enter idiocracy I grant you that is
possible maybe we are on that path well
we're certainly on it but maybe we don't
have to be on that path and that's the
point anyway John fedman went on the
televised mental institution known as
MSNBC to talk to Muppet Chris Hayes
about the the new rules related to
clothing margorie Taylor green said that
Senate no longer enforcing a dress code
for senators is to appease Federman is
disgraceful dress code is one of
society's standards that set etiquette
and respect for institutions stop
lowering the bar uh what what do you say
to
that well you know her platform you know
really she runs on more and more
dingling you know picks you know on uh
in the the me the meetings over in in
the Congress so again uh I I'm not
really sure why she cares how I dress uh
but you know she really takes it a
different I have no idea what that man
just said I have literally no idea what
he said he was asked about margorie
Taylor Green's feelings about the dress
code related to him something about
dingling pics like there's something
wrong with this man and we are all
watching it it's just like Joe Biden
it's just like Diane Feinstein it's just
like Mitch McConnell there's something
wrong with all of these people it's not
just what they wear and we all just kind
of Let It Go
here's a bit more from Mr fedman Senator
how things have operated since that deal
was a bipartisan deal was struck for
certain Topline spending numbers for all
of the funding bills that have to be
passed to make the budget keep the
government running the Senate has
basically been delivering those and
passing them by big 917 bipartisan
majorities the house today looks like
it's falling apart you've already got 17
no votes in that house Republican caucus
saying we're not passing anything what
what do you think Happening Here Yeah
you know like I truly I was I was very
proud of my colleagues you know because
they're really about governance that's
what it is and on the other the house
the the whatever they call themselves
Team America or whatever they call
themselves I just like hey I just like
bring your vote you know otherwise you
know they need to go hump a different
leg they need to go hump a different leg
uh obviously what they're talking about
here is this budget fight and a
potential government shutdown and no
matter what happens with the government
shut down and I suspect we'll be talking
about it more later in the weekend to
next week the Republicans will be blamed
no matter what frankly I wouldn't mind
if the government shut down and never
came back but that's sort of a different
story here the point is this guy
Federman he doesn't know where he is he
doesn't know who his opponents are his
dressing of of the hoodie now and and
something about the mustache where he
looks like an out of work porn star like
something about all of this not you know
they always say it's a porn star like
this is not someone who would be a porn
star he looks like an outof workor guy
who wanted to be inborn right but like
something about everything this thing
about these mediocre at best and that's
really I'm being very generous um that
these people have something to do with
our day-to-day lives is just crazy so
look while I agree that fetman is not
that bright and probably morally
bankrupt and philosophically bankrupt
and like just not right in the head um
he does make a slight point I think it
had something to do with the humping in
the leg thing that the House Republicans
aren't so great the Senate Republicans
aren't so great right we're not seeing
like the best of the best so now I want
to show you a clip uh this is from I
believe this is from yesterday uh this
is uh house leader Kevin McCarthy uh
talking to Maria bomo on Fox Business uh
about Trump and DeSantis try to make
some sense out of what he's saying here
all all of that the policies that you
mentioned of the bid Administration is
one reason that Donald Trump is leading
in the polls right now what's your take
on on this that as we see more
indictments of Donald Trump he seems to
be gaining in terms of popularity with
the public will he be the nominee I
think he will be the nominee and the
thing is President Trump is stronger
today than he was in 2016 or 2020 and
there's a reason why they saw the
policies of what he was able to do with
America putting America First making our
economy stronger we didn't have
inflation we we didn't have these
battles around the world we didn't look
weak around the world looks like santis
is now trying to work with your
colleagues who are pushing for a
shutdown yeah but I don't think that
would work anywhere a shutdown would
only give strength to the Democrats it
would give the power to Biden it
wouldn't pay our troops it wouldn't pay
our border agents more people would be
coming across I actually want to achieve
something and this is where president
Trump is so smart that he was successful
in this you know president Trump is
beating Biden right now in the polls
yeah we have the poll let's show it he's
stronger than he has ever been in this
process and look I I served with Ronda
santis he's not at the same level as
president Trump by any shape or form he
would have not have gotten elected
without president Trump's endorsment and
so I believe our best step forward pass
our appropriation bills so we're
stronger take the wokeism out secure our
border to make America stronger oh
there's there's a lot there okay so
first off I I agree with the good stuff
that McCarthy said about the Trump
presidency which is why I voted for
Trump the second time around right and I
was very vocal in my support uh about
Trump what's odd there's a couple odd
things first off Donald Trump is still
again whether you're magga base whether
you voted for Trump like Trump you like
the S doesn't matter Donald Trump is
still saying the election was stolen
from him right it seems to me that it
would be a problem in a functioning
Society if the leader of the house was
openly backing a guy who says that the
last election was stolen like he's
basically saying oh the whole thing's a
sham and and this guy is going yeah the
whole thing's a sham I'm going to back
him um it's it's a little bit odd there
and that's not to take away again from
the good things that Trump has done uh
but here's the stist responding to well
really he's responding to McCarthy but
going after Trump on this as well what
is your take on the fact that speaker
McCarthy now who was leadership back
then doesn't think that you're fit to
leave it's not your time well look I
would say I mean I think that if you
look at what's happened with DC
Republicans uh they worked uh very
closely you know look Donald Trump Trump
he supported Kevin McCarthy very
strongly for speaker I don't think he
would have won the speaker vote Donald
Trump was instrumental and him earning
that speaker gavel and they worked hand
and glove really throughout his whole
presidency they were on the same team on
every major spending bill that came down
the the Pike and they ended up together
adding $7.8 trillion to our national
debt never in a 4-year period has that
much been added than what they did
together and so he said that we're
different we are different because in
Florida we run budget surpluses we've
paid down almost 25% of our state's debt
just since I've been Governor all the
debt all the way up for all of Florida's
history we've knocked off almost 25% of
it so it's a much different approach uh
to where we're doing it right we have
the number one rated economy in the
country we've cut taxes we've expanded
school choice and we've delivered on in
a way that has made the state
sustainable uh I am not somebody uh who
the DC establishment wants to see up
there there's no question about I think
that last line is the key part it's like
McCarthy in a way doesn't want a guy
like Ronda santis who's actually going
to drain the swamp and change things now
I I happen to like Kevin McCarthy you
know I've interviewed him many times
including uh in that very room that he
was just sitting in uh with Maria bomo
uh so it's not a shot at him personally
but there's also a weird dynamic here
because Trump backed McCarthy for the
speakership as Dan santis referenced the
Bas hates McCarthy they think he's like
McConnell and everything else and and
Lindsey Graham like they think he's sort
of the ultimate swamp creature so you've
got Trump backing the ultimate swamp
creature while the base hates the swamp
like there's just all these strange
Dynamics but what what really this is
about is that to me Dan santis is the
guy he's being backed by the people say
Thomas Massie chip Roy he's being backed
by the people who actually want
government to do less who want you to be
tax less and have more freedom and it to
be slim and trim part of the issue with
the swamp is it always is expanding and
it doesn't seem to me that Trump or
McCarthy or Trump and McCarthy would
actually stop that thing from expanding
so DeSantis went on to say exactly what
he would do when he arrives in the white
house we in Florida have a right to
expect uh that they get some stuff done
for us like they said they would when
they campaigned because Florida was
instrumental in them even having the
majority to begin with this was supposed
to be a big red wave in 2022 you had
probably the most favorable conditions
that Republicans have had in a midterm
election since
1946 people were expecting a massive
tsunami because inflation was terrible
the Biden's unpopular all the problems
that we've seen nobody's happy with the
direction of the country and that's
tailor made for the opposition party to
be able to sweep into Washington DC
instead the only way reason they even
got the majority is because the governor
candidate New York overperformed and
because we delivered a red tsunami in
Florida that gave them an extra four
seats that's the story of the midterm if
you take that out the Democrats would
have held on to the House of
Representatives so Florida did its part
we showed how you can win uh and we want
to see some results um as a result of
that uh but I'm not somebody uh who's
ever going to be the favor uh favorite
uh of the DC establishment you know what
I wear that as a badge of honor you know
I have to say it's easy to support Dan
santis because tell me in the two clips
that we've shown you today any of the
lies there he's telling you this is who
I am this is who I'm going to be uh I'm
going to drain the swamp look what I did
here the Red Wave the only reason that
the Republicans even got the house was
because of what we did here in Florida
right it wasn't because of anything else
okay most of the the Trump back people
or not most but a good portion of the
major Trump backed people uh actually
lost and now I just want to juxtapose
what McCarthy said uh in the earlier
clip versus what he said to me literally
I think it's in that exact same room uh
this is back in March and when now he's
saying that you know sort of trump and
the swamp and everything else listen
listen to what he was telling me about
what he thinks a leader should sort of
be look like uh what a leader should
look like back in March what do we want
to
achieve okay you take everybody out of
running what do you want to achieve you
want to stop the bad policies so you
want somebody else in the white house
right so you got to understand too
what's the debate going to be about all
the things that Biden has done that
somebody else could do better I think
that resonates more with the public it
gets more people to vote it's about
addition not subtraction okay and so
it's tough when you get in a competition
but members should really see that
whoever runs and lots of times whoever
the front runner is today is not the
nominee and whatever we think the issue
is today is probably not going to be the
issue in another November from now um
but I think the Democratic policies will
always be the issue right and I just
don't
think the country wants another four
years of Joe Biden I just don't believe
we can sustain that and don't do damage
to one another that allows him to get in
because they're going to give you a lot
of bait don't take it note he did not
say Trump nor DeSantis in that entire
thing that was very slick so the reason
I wanted to show you that clip was
because he's being very specific there
who can deliver on the issues who can
deliver on the policies don't take the
bait and look we can all get we can all
get lost and he said this and he said
this and what's happening on Twitter and
all that and maybe I get lost in it too
uh but if you really care about the
issues and the policies then who do you
think the best candidate is I I think
there's a clear answer there it maybe
isn't the guy that's winning in the
polls right now but I think there's a
clear answer to the very thesis that he
put out there and everyone starts
becoming captured by things so I think
probably McCarthy in some to some extent
is a little captured by the Trump base
right now he sees the writing on the
wall so by conventional thought Trump
will be the nominee and he wants to get
in with that like that's just sort of
how politics work there are pundits who
do jobs similar to mine that don't want
to upset the base cuz it's going to get
you more clicks and likes and all of
that stuff like everyone is susceptible
to that and again as I addressed
yesterday I'm not saying I'm notet I'm
I'm completely impervious to that I try
to catch my blind spots and all of that
uh but if you really care about the
issues and the policies then there is a
clear answer Here and Now I want to
throw back to uh Trump's interview with
Megan Kelly a couple days ago because
this was a rare moment where I think
some people started waking up to some of
the confusion around Trump so here is
Trump on coid and fouchy I wasn't I was
not a big fan of fouchy if you look at
Ronda sanon is he was this guy said the
greatest things I can give you articles
that Fouch is great he's wonderful we
love him we don't do anything without
fouchy this went on for months but he
didn't listen to fouchy he did 100% look
he shut down I will give you he shut
down Florida for a month oh he shut it
down for a lot of long he shut down the
beaches he shut down the roads he he
shut down a hospital he was shutting
down everything he also had long lines
of people getting the jab as he called
it let's all go get the jab the guy
tried to change history in Florida now
eventually Florida was open but the one
that I love the jab as he called it like
no you called it the jab you literally
Donald Trump gave fouchy an award on the
way out everyone knows it you literally
like a month before you went out when
Dan santis had fully opened Florida were
still encouraging him to have social
distancing and the rest of it and I get
that we all didn't know what was going
on and all of that stuff but the point
is again I'm I'm listening to you
McCarthy on this one you care about
issues and policies who was more right
and it's fairly obvious that DeSantis
was uh here is DeSantis uh we showed you
this yesterday as well but I think it'll
get us to every to The Next Step here uh
this is DeSantis responding to Trump on
not even knowing whether he gave uh who
gave that award to fouchy in the first
place what was that was that the
immaculate Commendation that just
happened to happen it said Donald Trump
Awards fouchy this Commendation so I
thought it was really pathetic to to sit
there and listen to that driil um it is
it is totally false and you know what
people in your business and I know
you've you've spoken out there's a
people in your business who have their
own shows they know all that's false too
uh we'll see how many of them are
willing to step up to the plate and call
a spade a spade okay so my question for
you person watching this right now who
truly was better on coid was it Trump or
disantis who realized that things needed
to change and then actually changed
those things who's acknowledged that
they made mistakes and then went forward
in A New Path okay think about it you
you just for your own self who who
actually did that uh but it's not just
uh Co that there's a Divergence on uh
the other big thing that now there seems
to be some fighting about amongst
Republicans or conservatives or whatever
you want to call all of us is uh whether
a man can be a woman and Megan Kelly
asked Donald Trump the easiest question
imaginable and watch the
stammering can a man become a
woman
[Music]
um in my opinion you have a man you have
a woman I I I think I think part of it
is birth can the man give birth no no
although they'll come up with some
uh part of it his birth can a G man give
birth there there are many there are
hundreds of thousands if not millions of
women who cannot give birth they are
still women but why is he afraid to step
on anyone's toes is he already trying to
Pander to whatever Democrat might
suddenly flip to Trump in a in a in a
general election like is what is the
reason I saw some people when I put that
clip up on Twitter people were like he
didn't want to offend Caitlyn Jenner and
it's like uh but I don't know that
Caitlyn Jenner denies that Caitlyn Bruce
Jenner is still a man he has
transitioned and and lives Life as a
woman and so be it that that's just fine
you should live your life as you see fit
but that doesn't deny biology and now I
want to contrast that to Ronda santis
asking that answering that exact same
question here he is with Manny Johnson
asking about the greater issue of
transgenderism Dill mulany of course is
what kicked all this what do you think
about men taking the role of women and
taking really women's women's places in
advertising in sports playing against
them and this seems like an existential
threat to women uh a total fraud as
fathers of daughters have a swimmer that
competes on the men's team for three
years at pen and then switches to the
women's team and then wins the 500 yard
freestyle national championship for
women when you're mediocre male swimmer
and now you wi the women's and so you
had a second Place finisher she was
actually from Sarasota she should have
been the national champion I did a
proclamation from our office saying she
was the best woman swimmer in 500 yard
cuz she was and so some of this is yes
it's taking away opportunities and
Athletics and some other stuff and
that's really really important but I
think there's also just the issue of are
we going to be a society based on truth
or are we going to be a society based on
deceit and if you take a man and they
dress up as a woman and you tell me I
have to accept that they're a woman then
you're asking me to be complicit in a
lie and I just refused to do that you
got it again which one is true which one
is false which one is pandering and
which one is honest you know Brock made
a great Point as we were talking about
that McCarthy in the earlier clip that I
showed you there uh McCarthy was talking
about how Trump is stronger now than he
was in 2016 or 2020 except imagine Trump
in 2016 if he was sitting down with
Maria baroma or any or Megan Kelly or
anyone else and they said is there a
difference between a man and a woman can
a man become a woman he would have said
hell no that you know like it would have
been immediate and obvious it would have
gone viral it would have been refreshing
because it would have been against the
the cultural narrative and now he
stammers and stumbles through it so is
he sharper and stronger than he was in
2015 16 20 you have to make that
decision but something interesting and
this is really where I wanted to get
into the meat of the show is I I am
sensing something turning it is not easy
for someone that does something like
what I do for a living to upset a
portion of your audience and that's what
I keep talking about with audience
capture right you start getting an
audience because you say certain things
and then you might go oh maybe I was
wrong about that or the person that I
backed actually isn't who I thought they
were or whatever is going on and you
start saying something different and
your own audience can turn on you and
that can hurt you financially it can
hurt you careerwise for a series of
reasons it can be that you're not going
to get on this TV channel anymore but
something does seem to be happening in
the again whatever you want to call it
like the conservative or right space
online where pundits are finally getting
a little bit braver to call out this
nonsense so Megan Kelly went on who
again Megan Kelly did a bang up
spectacular job in that interview with
Donald Trump we were supposed to have
Megan on next week we actually pushed it
to the week after so I'll talk to her
all about her strategy around that how
you deal with that it's not easy uh just
sitting across from the former president
of the United States and doing all that
stuff we'll talk about all that but
anyway Megan Kelly yesterday went on
Glenn Beck's radio show and Glenn asked
her about Trump's answer related to
whether men can become women what was
your takeaway because he never really
answered it but he did shake his head no
towards the beginning what's your takea
away from that well I thought it was
weak sauce he I really wish he he did
better on that I like Ronda sanz's
answer I'm gonna be honest which is no
no right
no right no obviously no and it's not
determined based on who can give
birth it's determined by God and it's
pretty obvious just as soon as you come
out of the womb that's the way it's
always been that's the way it continues
to be notwithstanding this weird agenda
by some activists in this crazy trans
agenda pushing cult um so Trump clearly
knows that I don't know if he's got if
he's trying to like appease some group
of trans voters that he thinks is going
to make the difference with him even
when I had Don Jr on my show he was kind
of dancing around this issue I I think
that they think they're somehow going to
do better with Democrats if they don't
hit this straight on even though I mean
98% of the Republican party is United on
this issue this is not it is not a
winner for any Republican to hedge on
this um just ask ASA Hutchinson
you know maybe Megan is right maybe what
Trump is kind of trying to do is he's
saying I've got the primary wrapped up
which by the way he does not in the
first votes are not cast in Iowa until
January but maybe in his mind he's like
so I'll start the pandering now Donald
Trump he was sitting right in front of
me I would say it I would say Don Mr
President you know the difference
between a man and a woman and you know
that a man cannot become a woman but
maybe in his mind he's playing sort of a
cynical game he's saying ah I've already
wrapped this thing up so let me start
the pandering process right so I to move
now to the center which by the way all
candidates on both sides do this you run
a certain way in a primary because
you're trying to get as many of your
people going and then you need that
crossover group but in this case this
trans thing is so out of control that if
Trump's calculation here is somehow I
will not cleanly and clearly State
whether a man can become a woman or not
so that maybe I can get some Democrats
to vote for me it's like do you want to
support that you have to think about
that but Megan and Glenn who by the way
uh I I can't swear that that Megan voted
for Trump do do we know that for sure
she she certainly has been very friendly
to Trump's ideas in the last couple
years Glenn absolutely voted for Trump
last time I voted for Trump last time
but Megan and Glenn are talking about
this and it's good because we need the
full pundit class to at least assess
things as honestly as possible so I was
always I was also glad to see this clip
this is from Matt Walsh at the daily
wire who's I think certainly been a big
Trump supporter at least on the cultural
issues and he took it to Trump on that
trans answer obviously it goes without
saying that there's no reason to
hesitate on the can a man become a woman
question and there shouldn't be any
answer other than no okay if you're
saying anything other than
no anything the first words out of your
mouth after you hear can no then you can
you can elaborate on how crazy that idea
is first word should be no anything but
an immediate mediate no is a wrong
answer and also an embarrassment and if
if if that doesn't if you don't see why
that is then just imagine any other
basic scientific question getting that
kind of answer so what if you know just
to show you how ridiculous this is
imagine if Megan Kelly had for some
reason
asked um do you believe in gravity does
gravity exist and then Trump had said
um I well listen in my opinion uh you
know there are some who say that human
beings can fly uh but I think probably
not what what kind of answer is that
what why in my opinion but first of all
people are focusing on the um part of it
in my opinion you don't need to qualify
something like this by saying in my it's
not your opinion okay just like it's
it's not when I say gravity exists
that's not my opinion so in my opinion
gravity exist in my opinion uh the sun
is bigger than the earth it's not my
opinion that's just a fact it's not an
opinion at all so that was a weak and
convoluted answer where clear and
concise is needed when you as the
Republican FrontRunner give an answer
that makes it sound like a complicated
question you are that is just
you hand that that that's you
surrendering to the left on that
issue you know what it is you know what
it is it's a substitution of values
right when you go um in my opinion what
he's doing there in his brain is he's
trying to work out something because in
Trump's mind there he's extrapolating a
gajillion things she asked me a very
obvious question I know the answer to
the obvious question it's the answer
that Humanity has known throughout its
history the millenia but he's then doing
this game instead of doing what is true
what are connected to his values and
Truth he's doing a weird political game
and that is not what Trump would have
done in 2016 so I absolutely disagree
that Trump is stronger now now that
polls may not reflect that but the man
and the ideas and the thing that's
driving the movement it just is not as
strong and I'll give you another perfect
example of this uh the other thing that
has come up in the last couple days is
Trump criticizing DeSantis over the
heartbeat Bill uh now there are a couple
red states that now have a six week
abortion bill you guys know my feelings
on this already we had 15 weeks here in
Florida I was comfortable with that
there is no you know Trump keeps saying
I will when I'm in office again I'm
going to make everybody happy on
abortion it's literally the stupidest
thing you could say it sounds like a
third grader who's running for class
president when I'm in I'll make
everybody happy every everybody will
have cupcakes it's like you're never
going to make the true pro-life and the
true uh the true pro-choice people happy
you have to in a pluralistic society
figure out some things on the margins to
agree on it's also why states rights are
important so that if you live in a more
red state it can have more pro-life laws
and if you live in a blue state you can
have your 12mon abortion situation all
of those things which they'll have soon
enough yes 3 months after birth they'll
still be doing it but Trump he just he's
muddled on this and the line that he
said that really got everybody going he
wasn't just criticizing Dan santis for
six weeks and again you might think six
weeks is too much you might think six
weeks is too
far but Trump called the heartbeat bills
terrible he use the word terrible
they're terrible and as the guy that is
supposedly the most prolife president
ever and gets credit for bringing in a
court that then did overturn roie Wade
which was not a constitutional right
abortion it was a States right issue he
gets credit for that the idea that he
would say that a heartbeat bill is
terrible well a lot of people are
hitting him on that here's another guy
from The Daily wire here's Ben Shapiro
Donald Trump did a mainstream media
interview over the weekend it didn't go
amazing for him his his recent
interviews have not been going
particularly well this one was with
Kristen Welker the most newsworthy thing
that he said in this interview was he
made a comment suggesting that heartbeat
bills like to protect the lives of The
Unborn in states are terrible which is
not only not pro life it's an awful
thing to say it's one thing to say that
tactically speaking as president of the
United States I'm going to try to reach
as much consensus as possible and
gradually move the line back on abortion
to accustom the American people to
protecting life because if we move too
far too fast then the Snapback is going
to be dramatic as we saw in Kansas
that's a that's a pragmatic question and
that's a case you can make that's not
what Trump says what Trump actually says
about abortion in this interview is
morally egregious he says that heartbeat
bills to you know protect babies in the
womb past week five week six those are
terrible that's the thing he says a
terrible thing and a terrible mistake a
ter in the state he's not even talking
federally in the
state hey that that is not a pro-life
position by any stretch of the
imagination all right look everything
Ben said there was right I disagree with
Ben on what public policy should be
related to abortion and you can watch
old videos of ours from probably now
seven years ago debating abortion I've
shifted a little bit in that I I
actually think even 15 weeks is probably
a bit far you could probably push it
closer to 12 weeks but I absolutely
believe in exceptions and okay we can
again as I always say we can always talk
about all of those things but we will
never make everybody happy uh but Ben is
is completely right there on the
equivocation that Trump is doing that
somehow this is then terrible it doesn't
it doesn't really make sense so all
Trump's position that is so all we can
really do in the midst of all of this
and it's all going to get weirder and
crazier as you know this election year
rolls out and we're still we're still 12
months no we're still 14 months
basically away from the general general
election God help us all so all we can
do in the midst of all of that is is
tell the truth to the best of our
ability and let the chips fall where
they may if you're Megan Kelly you can
ask the best questions possible when you
sit down with Donald Trump if you're
Glenn Beck you can then ask Megan Kelly
what her feelings were about that answer
if you're Ben Shapiro you can tell
people what you think about these things
if you're Dave ruin if you're Matt Walsh
we can all do that and we can and then
you can do that I don't mean to make
this about the pundit class we're no
more important than you but you can do
that in in the dinners that you have
with friends and family and and whatever
would you go play in a basketball league
or you're in a kasta game or whatever it
is you do a knitting tournament you when
you talk about people when you talk
about the issues with people you can
really talk about them honestly if you
know what you believe and why you
believe it that is the challenge of
course there's another challenge coming
because uh with AI and algorithms uh the
truth may get muddled no matter what I
thought this would be a fitting way to
end Today's Show uh Elon Musk was in
they must have done they did this at the
Tesla Factory am I right I think this is
do we know that for sure I saw picture
yeah so Elon Musk was at the Tesla
Factory in Austin Texas uh with Benjamin
Netanyahu and they gave a press
conference after and they talked about a
whole bunch of stuff related to Ai and
algorithms and just all of the stuff uh
and Elon had a good line on uh truth and
how we see truth from a historical
perspective you know like there's an old
saying like uh history is written by the
by The Victors it's like well yes but
not if your enemies are still alive have
a lot of time on their hands to edit
Wikipedia history is history is written
by the people who can har is the most
editors yeah I mean you know the The Who
The Losers just got a lot of time on
their hands and uh you
know what are they do edit
Wikipedia literally there's something
there and he is right literally so the
the the general concept right history is
written by the winners why do the good
guys always seem to win it's because
they're the survivors then can write the
history we all like to think that we
have like an honest assessment of
history and I think from an American
perspective we we have a pretty good one
right we have a pretty good honest
assessment of what our history has been
and also that it helps also that our
history in America is only 250 some OD
years old almost 250 um so history is
written but but how this changes then is
what's happening in our modern world
with deep fakes with AI with Wikipedia
constantly being edited and then someone
goes oh I like da Ru I'm going to check
his Wikipedia page and you don't know
what nonsense they put on there trust me
there's nonsense on there like it's just
it's the editor as Netanyahu says
history will be who can ever Mind the
most editors you get editors you get
activists all of these things and one
day we will never know what's true so we
have a we have a truth war on two fronts
we have the truth and then two fronts
coming after it we have the people who
will lie constantly for political
reasons to to attain power whatever it
might be and then we also have the
machines and the algorithms who will
feed those lies and all of those things
it's that versus The Truth uh guys we've
got a little bonus for you today because
uh they are doing some backend stuff at
locals right now which I mentioned up
top which is why I thought we didn't
have a postgame show but in fact we do
have a postgame show and for this week
only the post game show is going to be
open to everybody as they do some tweaks
inside so it's not just for supporters
supporters are the only ones who can
comment correct but it's open I believe
supporters are the only ones who will be
able to comment and ask me questions on
the fly but every single one of you
watching this whether you're watching on
Rumble YouTube or wherever in God's name
this thing has been hijacked
you can join us right now at Ruben
report. locals.com for the postgame show
uh and we are switching our uh Thursday
no yeah we are switching our Thursday
Friday situation uh on Thursday we are
doing our Round Table this week we've
got doct Drew and Jeffrey Tucker coming
back for that and then our Q&A will be
on Friday we leave you if you can if you
don't puke while watching this this
speaking of AI if you don't puke
watching trans Biden here I'll be
impressed that we'll see everybody else
at report. locals.com in just a minute
Senator Vance recently asked the US
Director of National Intelligence along
with the secretaries of State in defense
if I was working in some capacity for
the American government simply put I'm
an American serving as a Ukrainian
infantry soldier in combat medic who was
brought from the zero line and assigned
to the tdfs media team in the Dual role
of spokes person and Russian
disinformation analyst the remaining
speculation surrounding me is
disappointing while in Ukraine we are
fighting for Global Liberty and the
ideology of Victory too many in Moscow
and across the world are still caught up
in focusing on the tire troop of gender
[Music]
chaos